wie wir ja mittlerweile wissen können
manche Pakete trotz intensiver
Nachforschung nicht beim Empfänger
zugestellt werden außerdem kann es
passieren dass Pakete von der L während
des Transportes beschädigt werden und
dann ebenfalls auf versteigerungszeiten
wie beispielsweise Aktionshaus Bella
landen fun fact man kann sogar alte
Betriebsfahrzeuge der Deutschen Post
erstellen
oh mann nachdem in meinen 5000 der
l-paketen echt ziemlich viel Schrot drin
war hoffe ich heute auf bessere Funde
und damit hey Leute was geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen Video
ich befinde mich hier gerade in
Österreich im Hotelzimmer aber ich
wollte unbedingt noch den Anfang für das
Video aufnehmen den Hauptteil habe ich
schon letzte Woche bei mir im Lager
aufgenommen na ja auf jeden Fall habe
ich Leute kontaktiert die meinten dass
Sie jeden Monat bei diesen DHL Auktion
da gibt's ganz viele verschiedene von
für mehrere tausend Euro einkaufen das
kann dann so aussehen ich blende euch
immer ein paar Bilder ein und mir mal
für einen Unboxing Video ein paar Sachen
rüberschicken könnten ich fand das ganz
interessant weil es vor allem auch teure
Sachen sein können und nicht nur
irgendwie so Kleinkrams wie jetzt bei
diesen 5000 der Paketen wobei da auch
teilweise coole Sachen bei waren neben
dem ganzen China Schrott genau und ich
habe für 1000 € und ein paar Pakete
abgekauft wieder zusammen Auspacken
werden und ja seid gespannt ob sich das
gelohnt hat und da sind wir auch schon
Leute was geht ich befinde mich mal
wieder hier bei mir im Lager und habe
den ganzen Bums hier mal aufgebaut also
wie ich euch schon erzählt habe hier
sind einige oder was heißt einige halt
ein paar von den Paketen die der Bree
mir geschickt hat ich muss sagen ich
habe keine Ahnung ob da jetzt schon
vorher reingeschaut wurde oder nicht ich
habe ihm einfach wie schon euch erzählt
1000 € überwiesen in der Hoffnung dass
es ein geiles Video wird bei unseren
5000 der alpaketen die ich letztens
irgendwann mal bestellt habe war ja auf
vielen Paketen noch eine Adresse drauf
hier haben wir das auch allerdings nicht
auf allen also hier zum Beispiel noch
eine Adresse drauf hier nicht aber hier
sind irgendwelche QR Codes drauf und ich
glaube das kann ich schon verwechs sagen
in dem Paket ist das Beste weil er
meinte das ist ein schweres Paket und
das soll ich mal am besten am Ende
aufmachen würde ich sagen fangen wir
einfach mal hier mit an und hier ist
auch leider schon irgendwie aber das
sind sogar irgendwie zusammengeklebt so
das sieht irgendwie aus wie eine Lampe
oder oder eine Backform boah das ist ja
wieder viel zu Crazy zugemacht oh ach
scheiße ich bin aber auch dumm hier muss
ich glaube ich ein bisschen vorsichtiger
mit der Materie umgehen weil das kann ja
schon wert und vielleicht ist das eine
Designer Lampe ich habe jetzt leider
hier rein geritzt ah nein es ist Deko
ich glaube ich weiß wie man das macht so
und dann kommt das hier drauf und das
hier drauf andersrum ah
alex hat den Bogen raus denn Alex ist
nicht dumm
Leute ich habe keine Ahnung kann mir
bitte jemand erklären was das sein soll
also ich habe jetzt gedacht es ist ein
Regal aber irgendwie
oder was ja auch sein könnte wenn man
das so nebeneinander an die Wand
schraubt ja ja und dann ah
wahrscheinlich soll man das einfach so
an die Wand schrauben oder hinstellen so
eins zwei drei tada kein Plan ob sowas
wertvoll ist falls sie es im Internet
finde wenn ich es euch jetzt hier ein
okay machen wir direkt mal weiter ist ja
klar das ist ja sowas ähnliches deswegen
war das auch zusammen das ist jetzt das
gleiche davon nur halt in quadratisch
wie kann man denn bitte etwas verpacken
warum ist das so krass eingepackt
ich habe es mir auch schon gedacht wir
haben hier einfach das gleiche in
quadratisch was noch tausendmal in
Luftpolsterfolie eingepackt ist diese
Dinger machen mich irgendwie sauer
wunderschön hier muss man nur sagen es
ist kaputt und ich glaube das war schon
vorher auch kaputt weil es ist total
verbogen bevor wir weitermachen würde
ich mich super freuen wenn ihr einmal
den Kanal abonniert vielen vielen Dank
aber ich muss sagen ich bin kein Profi
Dekorateur meine Wohnung ist auch sehr
schlecht alle sagen immer Alter hier ist
ja hier sieht ja aus wie bei Ikea ich
kann mir aber vorstellen dass das schon
wild kommt an der Wand bisschen verbogen
zwar aber na ja weiter geht's und das
sieht doch schön aus zack oh was haben
wir denn hier ist viel drin Unterwäsche
just ad water 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10
mal glaube sowas wie Unterwäsche oder so
Ladies oder man muss ja heute aufpassen
wenn man sagt für alle die sich fühlen
sowas tragen
bin mir gerade unsicher ob einfach die
Marke just ad water heißt wow das sind
echt coole Muster oder eigentlich noch
Preisschild sind ist dran ein bisschen
Preisschild dran nein design for you
glaube die Marke heißt cupsi wenn ich
jetzt für Instagram Pose macht man ja
schick und wir haben hier wirklich zehn
verschiedene Muster ihr habt ja gerade
gesehen noch sowas vielleicht könnte ich
sowas wirklich bei meiner Mutter
andrehen weil die trägt auch ja so also
ich glaube das ist eher Bademode für
Frauen im gehobenen Alter
beziehungsweise ja muss ich ja aufpassen
was ich sage ich soll jetzt erstmal ob
das was wert ist Bikini ich sag 40 € pro
Bikini guck mal hier haben wir sogar und
ich lag gar nicht so verkehrt ein Bikini
kostet Alter echt gut 30 bis 45 € habe
ich hier und ich habe zehn Stück davon
kennt man denn die Marke cupsi ich habe
das noch nie gehört die 1,1 Millionen
voll aber krass anscheinend werde ich
dir dann auch los wenn ich die verkaufen
sollte nur gerade ist ja leider nicht so
die passende Jahreszeit für Cappy moment
mal kurz 11 12 die habe ich vergessen an
sich hatte diese kleine Boxen UVP von
400 Euro schon mal gut okay weiter
geht's fangen wir mal was uns hier
erwartet ein Teppich ich kann mich mit
Teppichen nicht aus aber Teppiche können
ja auch wirklich Arsch viel Geld kosten
dieser Teppich ist zwar unfassbar
hässlich ich weiß nicht ob ich schon mal
so einen hässlichen Teppich gesehen habe
ach und in dem Teppich ist gleich noch
ein Teppich zweimal bunter Teppich guck
mal ob ich irgend eine Marke finde nein
nein erster Eindruck ist nicht gut ist
ein billig Teppich aber ich würde
trotzdem mal schätzen dass so ein
Teppich schon 20 30 € kostet vielleicht
sogar ein bisschen mehr wenn wir gleich
zwei davon also ein schlechter davon ist
was anderes nur für mich keine Ahnung
ist das nix und wir haben so ein Paket
noch mal und ich bin mir fast ziemlich
sicher dass hier auch noch mal ein
Teppich drin ist ja es ist ein Teppich
es ist ein und derselbe Teppich nur
diesmal in der etwas anderen Farbe ey
wenn ihr euch mit Teppichen auskennt
vielleicht kennt ihr sogar diesen
Teppich schreibt doch mal in die
Kommentare wo kommen die her und was ist
das für eine Marke und was für ein Wert
haben die weil ich habe den jetzt bei
Google nicht gefunden ist halt auch
einfach schwierig nach was soll ich da
suchen bunter Teppich es gibt halt nicht
mehr bunte Teppiche nur die die mir hier
vorgeschlagen sind sind alle deutlich
schöner als dieser bunte Teppich den ich
gefunden habe naja ein paar mann ich
will das große aufmachen das machen wir
zum Schluss manchmal sind hier auch
Nummern drauf wobei das hat mir bei
unseren 5000 derl-paketen auch auf
manchen Paketen ich habe keine Ahnung
was die Nummern zu bedeuten haben aber
gut wow ein Motor ich alter ich glaube
das ist ein Motorradhelm geilo vor allem
Motorradhelme ich fahre zum Glück kein
Motorrad ich finde es zu gefährlich ich
würde gerne machen aber das ist mir
einfach meistens nicht wert hey wie
krass einfach ein Helm von Virtu einen
Helm mit alter ein Helm mit Brille und
Freisprechanlage und wir haben noch
Handschuhe dabei den muss ich jetzt
erstmal aufsetzen ich weiß gar nicht ob
ich da reinpasse hallo wie geht denn das
auf hier moin sehr aus moin
und Brille ist eine Brille morgen in
Skiurlaub da könnte ich die gebrauchen
also ich kann mich echt nicht aus mit
Motorradhelm ich schätze aber mal der
kostet mindestens 150 wenn nicht sogar
noch mehr mit dem ganzen Equipment
hierbei ja gut also ist stabil ich habe
genau diesen Helm hier gefunden auch mit
der gleichen Freisprechanlage nur mit
einem anderen Muster für 131 Euro 99
hätte mehr gedacht oder mehr gehofft
aber ja trotzdem gut ne und es sieht ja
auch einfach lässig aus Motorradfahrer
die kommen ja immer überall richtig gut
an weil die so cool sind vielleicht gehe
ich jetzt einfach nur manchmal so ein
bisschen rum mit diesem Helm unterm Arm
damit alle denken ich paar Motorrad aber
naja geil schauen wir mal was wir hier
noch haben also hier hat auf jeden Fall
jemand schon mal reingeguckt weil das
Ding ist komplett auf aber schauen wir
einfach mal
oh Entschuldigung also ich bin mir nicht
sicher aber ich glaube das einfach so
ein Gitter für ein Kind oder für ein
Hund dass der irgendwo nicht lang läuft
oder was soll das sonst sein ja spannend
ja das kannst du wahrscheinlich so an
der Treppe befestigen dann immer auf und
zu machen okay wunderschön und dann
haben wir hier jetzt unser vorletztes
Paket das ist geisteskrank zugemacht
wahrscheinlich Schlitze ich jetzt wieder
irgendwo rein aber was soll ich machen
und in dem Paket wäre es gedacht ist
noch ein Paket und in diesem Paket was
in dem Paket ist haben wir Styropor und
hier haben wir eine Kinderlampe mit
Stern drin wow das Styropor ist aber
eklig ach so ich weiß ich hätte euch
gerne mal zum Leuchten gebracht das Ding
ist die ist direkt für die Decke oder
für die Wand wahrscheinlich eher wie rum
sollen das Gehen das verstehe ich nicht
ganz dieser Stern ist so rum und dieser
Stern ist so rum hä und hier ist auch
eine Fernbedienung bei die Frage ist wie
das Modell heißt ich liebe das ja
nirgendwo steht eine Marke drauf ne das
ist echt komisch ich habe jetzt echt
ewig gesucht kein Plan ich würde mal
schätzen das Ding kostet irgendwas
zwischen 30 und 200 Euro aber mehr kann
ich euch dazu auch nicht sagen aber mir
gefällt sie auf jeden Fall ich glaube
ich schenke die meiner Tochter ja Leute
ich habe euch was zu sagen ihr habt
einiges verpasst ich habe einen Joke
gemacht nein ich habe keine Kinder ich
bin ja selber noch eins so dann verstaue
ich das Sternenlicht mal wieder hier
drin ich habe die Verpackung schon
komplett demoliert zack zack zack zack
und jetzt kommen wir auch schon zum
letzten Paket hier bin ich jetzt mal
gespannt weil mir wurde gesagt dass soll
das Beste sein und wir haben ja schon
einige coole Sachen gut ich habe ein
Taube bezahlt dafür hat sich das noch
nicht so wirklich gelohnt aber wir sind
ja auch noch nicht am Ende Alter in dem
Paket ist erstmal noch ein Paket und
unter diesem Paket befindet sich ein das
ist auf jeden Fall teuer das weiß ich
ich mache jetzt erstmal noch das hier
auf hier steht sogar was drauf heißt
Bauhof also hier sind zwei von diesen
kleinen Paketen noch drin ah das sind
Tastaturen oder nee sind einfach so
Bügel für die Wand aber wozu genau man
die gebrauchen soll das weiß ich auch
nicht hier ist noch irgendeine Creme bei
German technology fix all Leute lest
euch das mal durch das ist einfach gar
kein Deutsch also manchmal fragt man
sich auch wer sowas produziert ne die
fünfte genceration mit C des
Nanostrukturen in Deutschland das macht
gar keinen Sinn aber ich würde sagen fix
all heißt das ist überall klebt und
vermutlich sogar sehr gut klebt deswegen
probieren wir das so einfach mal aus ich
wollte mich nämlich morgen früh eh
wieder auf die Straße kleben irgendwo
kann ich das doch gleich mitnehmen was
klebe ich denn jetzt zusammen ich
versuche einfach mal diesen Bügel an die
Wand zu kleben das wäre schon mal geil
wenn es klappt wie Pippi Langstrumpf
Spezialkleber und daran dann auch
Klimmzüge machen übrigens dieses Schild
habe ich letztens auch gefunden in dem
Paket Vorsicht Gefahr finde ich übelst
geil nicht zu viel Kleber ne ist auch
immer wichtig in meinem Papa erklärt
einmal oben und Kleber einmal unten
gucken ob das hält so oder ich mache es
einfach mal so nee eigentlich ist es ja
auch egal und dann jetzt kurz abwarten
ich warte jetzt einfach eine halbe
Minute ab und lass dann los ja
eigentlich müsste es jetzt schon halten
[Musik]
aber es war trotzdem ganz lustig und ich
glaube das Video ist auch ganz witzig
geworden wir haben jetzt einen Helm ich
habe ein Teppich ich habe ganz viel
Bikinis wenn ihr noch einen flotten
Bikini braucht im Sommer
Leute vielen Dank fürs zuschauen wir
sehen uns nächste Woche wieder gibt es
neues Video und ja haut rein ciao